the reality is that while Financial
Capital has been moving towards
addressing the climate transition it's
not moving fast enough and it's not
moving at the scale that we need so it's
really great to be here with you today
to talk about why we think that's
happening what we think some are the
some of the challenges are and and how
to address it so what are you seeing
well maybe we'll start with a little bit
of uh background the United Nations
estimates that we will need something in
the order of3 three to4 trillion dollar
per year to globally decarbonize our
economy through
2050 this shift and I know you you talk
about this as well will be the most
significant shift in economic history we
think it will be more extensive than
than the Industrial Revolution and
probably faster than the digital
Revolution and the good news is we are
seeing funds flowing to climate
Solutions the different news is that
it's as you said it's not nearly enough
it's not going to the hard toate sectors
and importantly it is not going to the
global South in fact we think that we
will likely miss every single one of the
17 sustainable development goals we've
been at this problem for for almost 20
years and we've seen enormous
incremental change but we need now
transformational change in our economies
in our businesses and our financial
institutions why has this been so hard
well it's a good question and it's
complicated for one thing but I think
there's probably four fundamental points
the first is the finance sector is
critical but it does rely on businesses
and on entrepreneurs to lead the way we
are financing their ideas and their
their their businesses secondly we do
need change in public policy and change
in regulation thirdly with the
investment Community we don't yet have
the tools to truly evaluate whether a
company or an industry is decarbonizing
we're making progress but there's still
work that we need to do and lastly we
need to fundamentally change the way
people think about capital allocation
and by that we mean we need to create
the capabilities for investors to
understand the impact of their
Investments within a traditional risk
and return
framework and all of this sounds really
challenging is there any good news there
is and we're both Optimist and there
that's right that's a good thing a good
place to be first of all there's no
question there's enough Capital there's
something in the order of $150 trillion
of Institutions who've committed to Net
Zero now we know that that's an
overstatement but the point is 150
trillion 100 trillion that's a lot of
money we we have the money to make the
transition secondly there are no legal
barriers we'll come back to this in a
little bit for investors to allocate
Capital to Sustainable Solutions thirdly
and we're seeing it yesterday we're
seeing it today there are amazing
entrepreneurs amazing business people
and the technology cost down curves are
happening even as we speak and as Al
mentioned yesterday
public policy is also on the Move we
have seen the inflation reduction act it
is the most significant climate
legislation United States and indeed
probably the world and the Europeans are
responding aggressively to decarbonize
their economy because of the tragic war
in Ukraine and lastly as we both know
Finance can change when my dad was a
portfolio manager at Ford Motor Company
late 60s early 7s the way he made
Investments was based upon limiting risk
that was their their job but then as
time went on people began to realize if
you could be paid for risk perhaps that
would be a better way to deploy capital
and so whole Industries developed like
the Venture Capital industry like the
growth Equity industry and of course a
high yield Marketplace so Finance can
change and that's going to be a very
important part of the of the solution
now we've been talking about sort of the
macro picture you're working on the
ground what are you seeing well you know
one of the reasons that I think that
that the finance pathway towards net
zero is so challenging is because it
touches every other pathway because
Finance encompasses the whole global
economy and so the finance transition
means supporting the transitions of
individual sectors of every country and
always paying attention to the needs of
individual communities as we get this
done but while we're doing and
supporting this work on the ground our
pathway still has to add back up to a
Paris aligned pathway at the end of the
day and so bringing together this top
down and bottom up effort is extremely
challenging but I think that the energy
sector itself which as you know is in
many ways the other key sector for
driving the transition provides a really
good example of this framework in
practice practice so the International
Energy agency the iea has told us that
as of last year Finance for clean energy
is actually equal with Finance for
fossil fuels which sounds like good news
right uh but the challenge is that by
2030 we actually need Finance for clean
energy to reach four times what's going
into tradition fossil fuels so we need
massive scale massive change in a short
amount of time and we need even more
than that to go into financing
transitions for individual sectors on
the ground for breaking down the demand
for fossil fuels as a way ultimately to
break down the
supply so when you think about these
three
buckets limiting Finance for fossil
fuels scaling up Finance for clean
energy and then investing to end the
demand for fossil fuels I actually think
that one of the greatest untapped or
it's being tapped but one of the
greatest forward-looking
opportunities is actually in that third
bucket where we break down the
demand and when we think about that
bucket one of the places where we need
to act act much more quickly is in
focusing on hard to Abate sectors these
are the most energy intensive sectors
that won't be able to run on solar and
wind things like cement steel Aviation
shipping which actually make up almost a
third of global emissions in total so we
really need to work to address
these but the good news is that we
actually
have a lot of the solutions to be able
to get these sectors to their goals and
thanks to
policy thanks to Rising demand for these
Solutions bringing down their costs and
thanks to technological improvements we
now see that the cost for the clean
Solutions is approaching or in some
cases is even lower than the costs for
the high emitting Alternatives so what
Finance needs to do is partner with
science continue to engage with
policy and work with Engineers to be
able to bring these Solutions online at
scale well we agree with you about the
harit to Abate sectors do you have any
favorite ones to to talk about well I
can't play favorites but if you were but
um one sector that I'm really excited
about right now is
Aviation because sustainable Aviation
looks ready to
scale one of the things that we're
seeing is that there's a rising amount
of corporate demand to buy sustainable
aviation fuel which is the key unlock
for decarbonizing this sector but what
we're also seeing is that the supply of
sustainable aviation fuel is not nearly
enough to meet that that demand or to
meet the goals for the sector even for
2030 forget about 2040 or
2050 and so what we need to do to make a
difference here is focus on multiple
production Pathways for sustainable
aviation fuel uh today most of the fuel
is is being produced using biofuels
which just isn't isn't fit to scale so
what we need to do is look at Pathways
which exist like we can make this fuel
out of ethanol we can make it out of
carbon even carbon dioxide that's been
captured from the atmosphere we can make
this stuff out of Municipal solid waste
not to be
trashy um and so the the example of
Aviation shows a map for how Finance
needs to partner with individual sectors
to get this done
yes we need to invest with Airlines and
give them long-term capital to achieve
their goals but also separately we need
to invest in the solutions that they
need to reach those
goals and I think that the aviation
sector also paints a picture of where we
need to go in this transition as a whole
why it's hard and why I'm
optimistic because the truth is that
there is a lot that we're going to have
to let go in this transition
uh and that's challenging we need to do
it in a just way uh but the other truth
is that there's also so much that we get
to create we need to let go of jet fuel
but we also get to invest in all of
these sustainable
fuels so what I see is a massive
multi-generational opportunity for
growth sustainable growth just imagine
creating a transition that is greater in
scale than the Industrial Revolution to
be delivered in less than 30 years it's
an unprecedented opportunity for
impact so I'm excited I don't know David
do you think that we can do this well we
we both are optimists and I think we
both have said it's going to be
difficult but we can do it we need
transformational change in our
Industries in our financial institutions
in civil society and certainly in public
policy but we have to remember and
understand and we're seeing it very
vividly now the impacts of climate
change are with us now and will get more
accelerated over the course of the next
couple of years Alan and I published a
oped in the Wall Street Journal in
November of last year talking about
fiary Duty and let us be very clear
investors who do not consider climate
are running significant risks in their
portfolios and are not fulfilling their
fiduciary
duty a pensioner living in a 5.5 degree
Fahrenheit as suppos Celsius 5.5 degree
Fahrenheit world with degraded
biosystems and rampant inequality will
not enjoy the fruits of their
retirement now we know can change it's
not static We Believe very strongly that
the role of Finance is to provide the
means for society to achieve its
Ambitions and the good news is climate L
investing is happening it is becoming an
asset class and so by creating
situations where Capital markets can
expand what they value to take account
of sustainability impacts will allow us
as investors to in fact act provide the
means for society to achieve its
objectives on the planet on people and
on
nature sounds good I say let's go out
there and do
it thank you
David thank
you